the cdc is encouraging americans to  avoid  all travel to more than 160 destinations  because of very high covet 19  risk while that warning includes mexico  americans still flying there for  getaways  popular all-inclusive resorts are also  increasing safety measures cleaning  includes electrostatic spraying  staff members walking through a  disinfecting fogger  free rapid antigen testing is also  available at many of these resorts  you just schedule the appointment three  or two days prior departure take the  test  five minutes and you're ready to enjoy  the pool again  here's the important part to note anyone  flying back to the u.s  must have a negative coveted test so we  did ask on twitter  do flight resort deals change your mind  about traveling during the pandemic  so far about 36 percent of you have said  yes  64 say no